I want to take a little bit of time to
talk about the reality of whether gun
safety regulations work to reduce not
just gun violence but violence more
generally because the right has a lot of
really concise and neat sounding talking
points I've said before the right has
the advantage on framing George Lakoff
has written about this abortion is
murder so it should be illegal that is a
really simple talking point and the left
position on abortion is not the opposite
of that it is nuance that is complex and
on guns the right has guns don't kill
people people kill people more guns
would make us safer gun-free zones are
the problem because only good guys
follow the rules and the bad guys will
bring guns into gun-free zones more guns
less crime people will find a way to do
the killing even without a gun so
banning guns are making them harder to
access doesn't do anything now there are
actually a whole host of ways to think
about this and all of them point in one
direction which is actually gun safety
rules and restrictions do work there was
a really good post on our subreddit by a
user named nostalgic sayin and some of
their ideas are in this segment now one
argument that's common is it doesn't
matter what you make illegal people will
get it if it's a good way to kill people
has anybody heard of a mass killing via
grenade grenades are easy to detonate
they have a big blast radius you don't
have to be nearly as accurate as you do
with a firearm yet there are no mass
killing incidents involving grenades
well why not
turns out there's really strict
regulation of grenades they're really
difficult to get another example m4 and
ar-15 rifles are very similar different
barrel sizes the m4 has some firing
modes three round burst and fully auto
firing options but all else being equal
em fours are harder to get they're more
expensive the mass shootings are
overwhelmingly ar-15s and never m4s wow
what a shocker
what about just in general fully
automatic weapons fully automatic
weapons would do a ton of killing in a
mass shooting but they aren't used
because you need to jump through
all sorts of legal hoops to get them
they're really expensive so the laws do
work the guns that are more difficult to
get and more expensive aren't used in
mass shootings so then some people will
bring up well the real problem is
handguns and individual homicides not
mass shootings and the types of firearms
used within them it's really a
distraction you can kill one person in
many many different ways and it is
difficult to stop a determined person
from killing one other person but the
success of mass shootings or mass
killing events is much more dictated by
the firepower and the destructive nature
of that firepower that's available and
if you zoom out and you look at studies
across many countries the theme the arc
is homicide rate goes down when gun
restrictions are made law but it's got
to be taken seriously it can't be just
one law there's a study published by
Oxford University Press what do we know
about the association between firearm
legislation and firearm related injuries
what we learn is that it usually takes a
pretty major legislative overhaul it's
not just background checks alone to see
significant changes restricting access
to guns and their purchase is associated
with a reduction in firearm deaths this
tells us that just passing background
checks is likely to have only a very
small effect what we need is a
combination of 100% universal background
checks
yes restrictions on the most deadly
weapons requiring permitting and
licensing for guns I'd like to see
mandatory insurance policies for gun
owners as well and Elizabeth Warren is
proposing a lot of this stuff and I'll
get to that a little bit later when you
look at countries like South Africa and
Australia even when you look within
States in the United States that have
made changes the results are very clear
but in the end none of this matters
because on this issue the facts don't
matter they are well-funded
on the pro-gun side they are well
equipped to dismiss any study and to
tell you that you're a bad person for
wanting the stuff and you're against
free
and in the end in addition to these
changes legislatively there has to be a
cultural change I've been talking about
this for years at this point we need to
stop being a culture where so many
people want so many guns we need to stop
being a culture where so many people see
guns as a tool to solve problems be the
societal political cultural personal we
need to stop being a culture that raises
so many radicals and extremists but we
also need to do all of these other
things which any other civilized country
would have done if they were in our
position which countries like New
Zealand so quickly did once they
suffered a mass killing event like this
so the policies work but they don't work
individually they need to be a package
of policies but the culture is a big
part of this and so many other things
relate to this
none of which none of which the pro-gun
fetishist American right-wing connected
to the very well-funded
gun lobby is willing to even consider
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman I hope you'll follow
me there I hope you'll follow the show
on twitter at david pakman show and i
hope you'll join me this evening 6:30
p.m. eastern time for a live stream on
twitch at twitch.tv slash david pakman
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath
this video two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video